[Musique]
tu as été vous avez bien mangé ça c'est
bon il ya un très gros bouffons sur la
voiture ce que je sais c'est pas bon ça
c'est pas moi qui vous écris pour
bouffer du sud bah moi elle a été comme
ça comment voulez vous passer je suis
j'ai acquis beaucoup son chéri gros
bouffons m'était conté malade elle n' y
avait pas écrit j'ai écrit dessus tu me
prends pas pour on attend je prends deux
voitures je suis à marquer de gros
bouffons marche prend une voiture se
moque barrabas parle c'est gros bouffons
battant ses voitures mais qui s'écrit
sur balles avec les castaldi 06 30 27
mais j'ai jamais chris hoy a dépassé sur
ma mission n'est pas sortie avec cast a
dicté à l'aigle est sûr de me draguer
rissman tu t'es fait draguer sidka
stadistes à un niveau d'acheter moi
j'arrive je me cherchais un 7/10 et
libanais reste à croiser elles ont par
contre moi je n'ai pas une bonne soirée
donc si tu peux prendre ta voiture et
partir d'ici
[Musique]
c'est votre voiture n'était pas comme ça
d'un problème tu l'as vu ta gueule à
vous excuser mon cul parce que c'était
comme ça vous l'avait amené la voiture
neuve comme ça c'est quoi la solution
laquelle vous monter dans la voiture
mais quand vous êtes dedans mais vous
voyez pas ce qu'écrit la fois dedans
mais j'ai dit moi je n'ai garé là après
moi je peux pas rester debout devant la
voiture c'est l'élevage totalité où
l'avez-vous montcuq adore faire cette
date vous jure c'est dans j'adore ça
s'appelle que j'ai ouvert parce que les
gens quand il crie ça les gens qu'on
écrit ça je vous jure c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont fait ça pour la blague au jeu
par gros tu t'y serait le comte dooku
alors vas-y parle ça c'est quoi
j'ai des petits ponts avec les mobiles
avec les trottinettes la voiture et soit
nettoyé mais nous on a un service de
lavage mais un poche pour la cuvée
responsable dû l'être du nettoyage chez
moi ou pas responsable responsable tu
veux pas parler avec moi qui va
fatalement il s'est pas lavé des
voitures depuis 76 il a jamais laver une
voiture donc on a faim le super bizarre
mais c'est perdu tu veux qu'on appelle
le chip le superviseur on va
j'appelle super bizarre tu seigneur
sourire masculin service nettoyage du
lavoir voilà je croise les bras devant
chez moi j'ai une journée de garde au
scion woman d'attac fou mais c'est quoi
ça tu veux acheter 10 et très gros beauf
ou au niveau de votre cul parce que je
trouve à la blague de terre c'est quand
quelqu'un dit tu l'as vu jeudi qui es tu
réponds montcuq et ça fait une blague
est ce que ça fait là là tout de suite
maintenant levé les écritures ça ne
viendra pas et un petit bitume est donné
comme ça m'est témoin je sais pas je
suis rentré par un protégé traverser là
je vais pas vous raconter d'où cette
fois ton prénom ton nom mohamed ouahmed
on va trouver une solution et je connais
des carrossiers mois mais non pas
tricard aussi opaque à rossi jean cauchy
toi te refaire des métaux parfois - sap
la voiture sur le toit mais à 47 des
joueurs qui me tient jusqu'en 1/4 aussi
jeter tiges parfois dc100 que la voiture
soit nettoyée je connais un carrossier
c'est le meilleur de la place donneront
pas les coûts tout car outre il
s'appelle qu'on écoute moi moi m
calme-toi j'ai tenu un quart aux séries
le meilleur carrossier de paris cyril
hanouna meilleur carrossier de séparer
ou travers toi c'est une grande joie
[Applaudissements]
samir la grande brasserie avec cyril
hanouna sans ma voiture
tu mavuba couture
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais remercier mon frère aux
hinault et je veux bien mais bon c'est
la question pourquoi c'était pas comme
ça qu'on revient avec la voiture
sachez que poserait mon moi ça me rend
fou mais les gens ils viennent d'un quoi
et son naturel pourquoi c'était pas
comme ça j'aurais écrit gros bouffons et
comme ça c'est excellent excellent et
nous avions d'ailleurs